mais la question qu'on me pose déjà sur
twitter ce soir c'est si edouard
philippe à la bonne méthode à la bonne
méthode c'est la question qu'on vous
pose et qu'on se pose notamment après
avoir entendu cette annonce du premier
ministre ce midi déclaration sur cette
fameuse conférence de financement des
retraites à l'issue de la rencontre avec
les partenaires sociaux au ministère du
travail
j'ai proposé à l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et patronales
de nous retrouver vendredi matin à
matignon pour réfléchir plus exactement
pour déterminer ensemble quel pourrait
être le contenu de cette conférence des
financements l'idée est bonne et nous
devons mettre d'accord sur le mandat de
cette conférence de financement sur le
délai qui lui sera accordée pour aboutir
ou proposer des solutions ou dégager des
solutions consensuelles
jean claude casanova je crois que c'est
le cardinal de retz saint qui disait
qu'on sortait de l'ambiguïté qu'à son
détriment
hélas pour l'instant on on sent dans une
parfaite ambiguïté est-ce que c'est
habile de la part du premier ministre
bien finalement est-ce que ça masque un
recul sur l'âge pivot que j'ai pour
principe de ne critiquer une position
politique que si j'en ai une meilleure à
proposer je n'ai pas d'autres
propositions à faire donc je n'ai pas de
critiques à formuler mais je comprends
tout à fait son attitude
à partir du moment où la cfdt reconnaît
qu'il ya un problème budgétaire il
propose un organisme qui débattra du
problème budgétaire il n'a pas dit
d'ailleurs dans l'énoncé concernant
cette compo cette commission sa
composition
comment seraient tels composés donc tout
dépendra de la composition drainer
derrière
oui tout dépendra de la composition de
la commission et des pouvoirs et du
calendrier qui lui seront données mais
pourquoi pas s'ils voulaient après tout
ce qui me gêne un peu dans la réforme
actuelle si son excessive centralisation
sont excessives détachement par rapport
aux populations concernées tout dépendra
de la composition comme disait jean
claude casanova lui s'il est ce que
et question subsidiaire est ce que la
cfdt a raison encore d'appeler à
manifester a renoncé à acheter vos alors
que pr ministre quand même envoie des
signaux clairs sur l'acceptation de
nascar qui ont peur depuis plusieurs
semaines on n'arrête pas de dire qu'en
fait le gouvernement a envie de deal est
en fait de négocier vraiment avec la
cfdt et pas avec les autres syndicats
qui de toute façon enfin en tout cas
pour la cgt propose le retrait de la
réforme
donc là je pense que le gouvernement a
saisi la balle au bond puisque laurent
berger a proposé cette conférence de
financement d'ailleurs edouard philippe
dit c'est une bonne idée donc il reprend
l'idée d'un autre après il propose une
réunion vendredi je rappelle que je dis
il ya une grande journée d'action est
que samedi il ya aussi une grande
journée d'action donc on est et propose
en sandwich entre jeudi et vendredi de
faire cette réunion est la question ces
milieux les onglets voilà en tout cas ce
qui est clair c'est qu'il sera au tour
de la table qu'est ce qui va en sortir
c'est une idée de la cfdt chouchou pas
sûr que la cgt ou d'autres syndicats
soient d'accord et donc ce qui risque
d'en sortir vendredi c'est l'image d'une
désunion syndicale est sans doute un
durcissement de ceux qui veulent le
retrait de la réforme donc avec la
conférence de financement vendredi moi
ce que je pense c'est que samedi on
risque d'avoir une vraie journée de
mobilisation est donc je ne sais pas si
c'est la méthode vous demander de parler
sur les méthodes edouard philippe
moi je vois bien que là ils essayent de
trouver des alliés mais trouver des
alliés ça veut dire clairement désigné
ses ennemis et ça veut dire que laurent
berger dont doit désigner ses ennemis
chez les autres syndicats donc ça semble
une manoeuvre assez compliqué et je
pense qu'il aura eu intérêt à dire
on accepte de reculer sur l'âge pivot
c'est à dire que moi je trouve qu'il ya
un moment où il faut arrêter de dire
écoutez on doit se parler on doit
discuter on doit prendre le temps en
fait grosso modo ça fait deux ans qu'on
prend le temps donc je suis sceptique
christophe c'est ce que vous décoder
discours du premier ministre
aujourd'hui mes côtés pour tout vous
dire moi je suis je suis venu ici pour
entendre de grands esprits parce que moi
pas comprendre toujours pas cette ni la
méthode ni la communication ni le fonds
paulson nicole mehdi franchement on se
demande ce qu'ils ont fait pendant les
deux ans de discussions avec de leveau
parce que du point de vue il ya erreur
de communication comme on dit mais moi
je te dirais plutôt qu'il ya erreur de
timing sur beaucoup de choses le fait de
sortir ça en décembre juste avant les
fêtes
le fait de mettre dedans la réforme
paramétrique cia il y avait je l'avais
pris sa science po autre foyer bien il
ya un théorème d'économies que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'il a été produit par
un prix nobel néerlandais qui s'appelle
kinberg anne qui disait quand on a des
objectifs politiques il faut avoir
autant d'instruments que d'objectifs et
là en l'occurrence cette réforme elle
veut faire un peu tout c'est à dire
régler le problème des régimes spéciaux
régler le problème des carrières hachées
rétablir la justice sociale etc
et en plus rétablir l'équilibré
financier
et tout ça avec cette réforme dont nous
attendons toujours de comprendre ce
qu'elle raconte est fait vous avez le
fameux retard du simulateur etc
c'est à dire que peu importe mais je ne
suis pas concerné est en panne et hélas
après 1975 mais je pense être concerné
par ce qui arrive aux autres remarquable
remarque mais mais mais mais je je je
préfère éviter ce ce point de vue est le
cas de le dire puisque c'est la
rhétorique de la cgtg le plus grand
doute sur le fait qu'il soit non
concernés par les autres donc je pense
que dans cette affaire chacun suit ses
intérêts moi je vous savez celui de
grave donc je crois beaucoup aux
intérêts donc en la matière je suis
concerné d'une façon directe
c'est-à-dire qui paiera ma retraite
incombe bien sûr ces répartitions et ben
alors
fragile mais il ya une réaction sur
lesquels jouer avant justement votre
commentaire c'est celle du précédent de
l'artisan de la précédente réforme des
retraites c'est eric woerth qui réagit
c'est justement cet après midi à ce que
disait edouard philippe
c'était à l'assemblée nationale face à
la contestation vous multipliez les
concessions si bien que nous risquons
aujourd'hui de passer d'un système
universel pour tous un système
catégoriel c'est à dire le contraire de
votre objectif initial
par ailleurs si on en croit vos
déclarations vous accepteriez l'idée de
séparer l'organisation des retraites de
leurs financements
c'est évidemment inséparables et vous le
savez très bien alors al'inverse adrien
cat-nat celui accusent le gouvernement
de mise en scène iggy dans un tweet le
projet de loi avec l'âge pivot lui a été
transmis au conseil d'état dont il n'y a
pas de recul de la part du premier
ministre
ce qu'ils ont conseillé le pr vénisse
n'a pas dit parce qu'ils essaient encore
de sauver ce qui peut l'être
il n'a pas dit je renonce à l'âge pivot
mais je crains parce que sur ce point je
diverge absolument de ce que dit lucie
et bien sûr je crois qu'il est mis le
doigt dans un engrenage qui est ni les
cta blement conduire à l'abandon de
l'âge pivot il entre une logique de
dissociation
on peut entre en dix ans durant a dû de
dissociation entre la question de
l'équilibré financier et la question de
la réforme systémique
je crois moi qu'une réforme qui ne prend
pas en compte la dimension financière ne
sait absolument rien et même dangereuse
là le me semble-t-il la première
question des retraites c'est selon elle
vers c'est la question que se pose est
lancé aux régimes de retraite à quel
niveau sera t-elle on va voir comment ce
sera versée sur quelles bases du
trimestre du point de tout ça c'est
sûrement très important mais la base de
la base en matière de retraite y est ré
jamais souhaité combien aurais-je est
donc une réforme
d'ailleurs sinon c'est trop facile de se
retrouver aussi de faire des réformes si
on fait des avances sans s'intéresser à
la façon dont ceux des finances
donc je pense que la grande digue était
de nouveau
votre ferme temps ben oui mais la grande
clé de toute réforme c'est de changer
les choses en assurant les qui la
durabilité de ces choses sinon c c'est
un exercice d esprit donc jusqu'à
présent macro avait réussi à obtenir un
accord
edouard fini pour obtenir un film
additionnelle d' obtenir d'eux macron
l'idée de la de joindre l'aspect
financière l'aspect à l'aspect
systémique l'aspect appoint universel et
patati et patata
ce qu'on voit et ça fait pas et je pense
qu'ils doivent absolument pas le choix
parce qu'on m'a connu mais la pression
dessus des 10 faut rien compris à vide
il est en train petit à petit abandonné
et je moi je le regrette
la dimension financière pas il n'a pas
encore dit mais demain quand il y aura
cette réunion qu'est ce que va dire et
qu'est ce que va dire le berger médias
nous on se réunit mais évidemment pas si
vous laissez l'âge pivot dans la réforme
puisque on va discuter de comment
rétabli l'équilibré donc défendre vous
enlevez l'âge pivot des réformes et donc
s'il n'y aura pas de réunion et la danse
philippe ne veut pas maintenant qu'il a
convoqué cette réunion il ne veut pas
s'exposer un camouflet de berger
claquant la porte et dix ans je
n'assiste plus les réunions donc dé
facto on enlèvera il paraît même que ça
n'y ait pas d'ailleurs on enlèvera la
question de l'âge pivot dans le texte de
leur énorme et on transmettra à cette
commission le soin deux mains d'imaginer
les voies et moyens de revenir l'
équilibre
ce qui évidemment elle ne fera pas on ne
reviendra pas dans six mois dont trois
mois dans quatre mois en disant gens qui
a dit un truc que vous avez dit vous
allez travailler plus longtemps si on ne
le fait pas maintenant on sait qu'on ne
fera plus qu'à la fin du quinquennat
là ils y reviendront plus et sur ce
qu'on fait trop peur ce coup ci ça
dépend de ce qu'il sortira de la
discussion parce que l'argument de
philippe consiste à dire je suis prêt à
discuter sur l'âge pivot à condition que
vous fournissiez des moyens de
financement
donc on est bien obligé il ne peut pas
pardon entre le désir et va mais depuis
le début laurent berger dit mais on a
des réserves
on a des moyens de financement
sans pouvoir sans toucher à l'âge pivot
c'est ce qu'il a dit et puis c'est tout
mais justement c'était pas si grave les
déficits d'abord il n'a pas tant que ça
en fait tirés des réserves
et puis enfin vont augmenter un peu les
cotisations et on n'aura rien réglé sur
ce point quand même bien fait je suis
quand même ce dossier tous les jours
c'est la première fois que j'ai entendu
aujourd'hui quelqu'un dit qu'alain
problème dans la communication quelqu'un
dire qu'ils soient journalistes hommes
politiques que le système est
aujourd'hui en déficit
aujourd'hui 2,4 milliards exactement
vous l'avez entendu dire dans la
communication gouvernementale en avril
un déficit de 4 milliards n'ont rien de
social c'est déjà quelqu'un d'assurance
il est financé par la dette dont donc il
ya un déficit actuel du système
avec la contribution des tas de 4
milliards d'euros pourquoi est ce que on
ne l'a pas entendu pendant trois mois ça
parce qu'ils ne se seront pas exprimées
clairement c'est tout et encore est ce
qu ils se sont même raconte au début qui
avaient pas les moyens je pense que ce
temps-là coller le corps le style des
forcément mais mais mais ce sont à côté
de l'udc avait pas de problèmes
financiers le 6 le nom moi ce qu'il
semble important en dehors de la
question financière qui effectivement
l'état a encore les moyens d'abonder et
le corps à attirer l'attention mais en
disant qu'ils avaient pas une extrême
urgence à réformer donc c'est ça qui est
important
non mais c'est ça qui est à dire c'est
pas sucre non journée vraiment retard et
je sais pas si que l'argent n'est pas
morte et enfin c'est quand tout cas non
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui il ya mille
choses qui est une évidence et que la
région ile de france est bloqué
d'ailleurs le reste de la france est
moins bloqué que
et moi bloqué de la région ile de france
et moi je trouve je suis pas journaliste
mais je trouve qu'on l'a assez peu dit
alors même que là il ya quelque chose
sont singularisés dans les sondages
pendant ce qui n'était pas en ile de
france qui dépend la province yaro mais
en tout cas ce qui est important c'est
que quand on quitte la région
ile-de-france on s'aperçoit de ce qui se
passe sur l'embolie l'espèce
d'affrontements de pouvoir qui est en
train de se passer et ça ne l'a pas
assez dit je trouve depuis un mois la
deuxième chose me dit si on les interdit
de 10 des internautes qui sont en région
qui sont par neil de france disent nous
on voit ça deux points de vue mais en
tout cas cette conférence de financement
heureusement qu'elles existent pour pour
edouard philippe pour avoir une porte de
sortie dactique mais c'est clair qu'elle
introduit quelque chose de complètement
différent et que du coup tout ce qui
s'est passé avant ça risque pas moi je
trouve de relégitimer le gouvernement
pour être franche
parce que jusqu'à présent on n'a pas
parlé et qu'on arrive sur un nouvelle
proposition qui semble sorti du chapeau
à qui n'est pas sorti du chapeau du
gouvernement et donc qui donne vraiment
le sentiment qu'il ne maîtrise pas ce
qui est en train de se passer
donc je pense que du coup samedi la
journée peut être assez dur et qui
risque en rompant le front syndical on
risque d'avoir quelque chose qui est
assez préoccupant en termes de violence
et d'impunité
si si je peux défendre le gouvernement
si je veux gagner c'est relativement
simple c'est à dire il lui faut une
victoire contre la cgt uniquement contre
ceux qui sont contre le système et cette
victoire il obtiendra vraisemblablement
par l'usure de la grève d'une part et
d'autre part par un compromis de façade
ou réel avec la cfdt concernant village
comprend une image
ben oui pourquoi pas mais on va voir sa
victoire en politique a une très grande
importance est d'ailleurs curieux de la
part de la cgt de s'engager dans une
bataille que logiquement ne peut pas
gagner mais c'est une affaire de vie ou
de mort d'une certaine façon a dit la
cgt
une victoire à la fois philippe et la
cfdt la cfdt a peur de perdre des plumes
à gauche bon elle en perdra un peu mais
l'on gagnera en respectabilité
financière
mais quelle victoire elle est soumise
victoire médiatique encore
que même j'ai l'impression que plus
personne n'y croit moi je remets à court
terme et à moyen terme aux dangers des
racks une défaite mais je pense que le
figaro dira le compte y est pas parce qu
il ya plus de régime
il n'ya plus apprécié au ont été
transformés en régime spécifique ce que
disait woerth
j'ai tout ça va coûter des milliards et
il ya plus d'acheter vos donc a pas de
mesures d'âge
donc en gros la droite n'y retrouvera
pas son compte et la gauche en voudra
toujours mortellement ce gouvernement
d'avoir essayé de l'étrangler les
pauvres genre et à la fin des fins je
crains que ce gouvernement il perdre sur
les deux tableaux
évidemment il faut choisir où on jamais
si oui on fait solution choisie moi mais
là ils vont perdre des deux côtés il ya
un risque d'accroissement ddv la gauche
la gauche de gouvernement il y aura
aussi beaucoup perdu et parce que la
vérité c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
contre proposition portée par une gauche
de gouvernement la gauche n'existe pas
oui mais non mais la gauche tous bords
du vent peut-être qu'en ce moment elle
ne peut pas même continuer à exister
dans les choeurs sur le vôtre en tout
cas c'est le coeur il existe sur le
player du figaro pour lui s'il échoue il
ferait mieux de sortir des simulateurs
réelles sur des situations direct de
retraite du secteur privé mais là ils
risquent d'effrayer nous dit citoyen
payeur et romain oui nous avons des
raisons de coût de cette affaire comme
un vrai sens
il faudra quand même qu'on mesure le
coût jabot le coût de la grèce à b le
coût financier des mesures qu'on est en
train d'accorder à tous ces régimes les
après quinze 15 milliards et aux
enseignants je dis pas que c'est pas
bien de revaloriser les enseignants mais
c'est une histoire qui va coûter par
paliers jusqu'à 10 milliards par an sur
15 ans et après il ya près de 10
milliards par an par an il va bien une
fois qu'on les augmente être chômeur
figaro est accusé de faits que news mais
c'est la pure vérité c'est une pure et
le ciel pure vérité folie faut lire ici
la pure dorit et mais les suisses et des
allemands arrivent à financer les
enseignants de la même façon avec moins
de déficit n'est légale mais faisant
faisait peut-être peut-être en leur
demandant de travailler un peu plus mais
pour ça il ne faut pas leur dire que
l'argent qu'on leur donne et la
compensation de les retraites il faut
aller leur dire 'vous trail est un peu
plus haut et plus d'argent c'est le bon
sens même sauf que maintenant on leur
dit
l'argent ça va être contre les retraites
donc demain ne pourra pas leur dire ah
il ya un truc que vous avez pas dire ici
la preuve est touché et malté du
gouvernement c'est ça oui ça ne pouvait
pas demander à un ministre de
l'éducation de dire des choses qui vont
mécontenter les enseignants et allègre a
essayé avec le résultat qu'on a vu et il
faut qu'un ministre de l'éducation 10 ou
d'enseignants on va revaloriser vos
carrières très ça correspond à un
déficit et que nous avons passés dans
gmail et la revalorisation fils cela
paraît logique pour le découvre à
l'occasion d'une réforme et ceux qui a
tué c'est un peu bizarre
jusqu'à vous auriez pas les moyens tours
a tenu à nous aimer les simulateurs mis
en place par le snes ont tué une grande
partie la réforme proposée par le
gouvernement
absolument j'ai écouté la méthode
philippe quoi qu'il dise de toute façon
les syndicats et grévistes se
rencontrent et défileront la referme
devrait être arrêté dans sa c'est ce
qu'estime chiche et babineau qu'on salue
le gouvernement est comme tous les
autres internautes du figaro a toujours
été ouvert la discussion sur l'âge pivot
je doute que l'abandon ou le retard de
l'âge pivot soit si grave eh bien on
continuera d'en débattre surtout si il
est abandonné